welcome to another edition of weekend
scramble oh yeah this week we've got
lookout parrot good human an angry
groomer I don't know any of those but
let's let's get into it so I can find
out milk out parrot
look out the hair oh that's pretty good
parrot look out pop oh whoa we're come
to Poland I come to polish exactly I
don't even need to show you the video
Parris all have the same [ __ ] voice
they do huh
yeah you know people in my aunt parrot
sounds just like her she's like this
very strong deep voice Mexican woman
that [ __ ] she just cusses ten words
in one sentence and the exactly like the
[ __ ] fed the same words you don't
hear it you think my dad's home but it's
just the bird oh yeah no but she goes
faster she wait they come on you can't
even imitate it so fast
yeah it's poetic probably that Escobar
bastard epic alien sounds captures all
the Spanish that she was so funny one
thing let's be less I mean kinda [ __ ]
crack me up anyway okay so this parrot
takes place in Brazil and you said this
parrot takes place in Brazil this parrot
period ok this takes place in Brazil so
it was this this police raid we're gonna
crack dealers and they they got crack in
Brazil
and so this bird had been taught to
learn to criminal eart the criminal
that's tight - whenever police were
right they would shout in Portuguese mom
the police em um yeah mum well here's a
video of what parrot looks like and so
they're saying that this is a very
obedient parent parrots because it has
not said a single word has been
completely silent
parody no snitch yeah that's amazing
do they have graphics on their police
code oh that's a camouflage the pair
won't even look through the camera dude
that's how beautiful he hasn't said one
word not what's wrong word he's been
completely silent I'm sorry he's loyal
to the game this parrot is better than a
lot of [ __ ] humans yeah dude I just
picture who doesn't want to die that's
what just plucking out the parrots hairs
to get him to speak
oh it's Brazil that's what they do
I'm trying [ __ ] [ __ ] you what if I pull
up another feather Bob I could be born a
[ __ ] West Side with two wings like
this dude I don't know if my dogs would
ever do something like that
it's just start speaking English to
write you out yeah maybe we just sit
down and just start like giving it all
up you're very interesting dogs though
they would like lead you to the stash
the really good house is a very
interesting tick like when he's happy to
see my father me love ya meatloaf has a
very interesting tick he likes to bite
dicks it's really excited and he goes
what the [ __ ] is what the dick nibbling
dude [ __ ] nibbles on your dignity
excited to see you [ __ ] that's why
he's nibbling at your dick ken I can't
help it he looks just like [ __ ] I
[ __ ] went like that and smack them
real quick anyway any walk away he acted
like I frickin punched them
yeah it was just nibbling on puppies and
dicks all day did I remember I took him
to the groomer like him in fog and then
so like fun is such a good girl she
listens and then meatloaf was kind of
difficult she like come on and I barely
saw you see my dogs I'm like oh my god
we're gonna call the cops yeah for real
two feet he does that it happens at the
dog park all the time or he walks by and
you know when you just go like that like
you I don't know that's gonna come
flinters yeah like
that he's a huge dog - he's funny now
literally see him try even talk before
he tries to eat dogs like other dogs oh
yeah yeah he's weird he's a weird guy
but anyway this parrot here so they're
saying that a lot of criminals in Brazil
are using animals and their drug trade
and most of them have been reptiles like
for example by 2008 police seized two
small alligators that were found on a
raid you're not saying [ __ ] either in a
favela so another we need to get copper
dial on this [ __ ] copper dial on this
were these stuff in them
like stuff in the animals full of
cartels does that I don't know
they're just mentioning that they've
been using a mostly reptiles I don't
know for what cause cartel stuff dogs
and stuff they'll be like duck dog star
ball of coke oh man I ruined my image
man header like my life oh that sucks
because when I thought about when I
thought about drug dealers using animals
you know how Brazil is very tropical I
just saw monkeys like swinging in the
vines with a [ __ ] kilo of cocaine and
then passing it off to like they have
backpacks
no they're just holding on to it and
then and then they pass it off to like a
what do you call it like a rhinoceros or
something well that's in Africa but you
know they they all work in a unison
that's what I saw and you go to the
crack factory and then monkeys are just
this kind of make me feel happy oddly
happy about the dress
oh you argue together that's a nice I
didn't like they just put all the crack
on the birds and then all the birds fly
off and then they go to the respective
customers yeah well now Thank You bird
and then they get the crack and they
smoke like the ghetto Cinderella story
and the gangsters and the gangsters are
like super hard but then there's super
good friends with the animals too and
they all care about each other I don't
like it's a team these are gross to me
they're just disgusting I like the
chamber same Uli's I just saw monkey
recently I don't know what type of
monkey but it's some sort of primate
that was using Instagram
chimpanzee it was actually scrolling
like a human like that's why I'm saying
the [ __ ]
we click on a photo and then fly it out
to go back to the page oh [ __ ] I read an
article where they said that bucket
primate forgot what type but they found
religion and [ __ ] you're evolving the
Stone Age right there two leaves no
tools that is nuts that's why I'm saying
they're gonna catch up kill us I mean
this long - I think that's the whole
thing with Planet of the Apes is like
but if we accelerate them and then they
which they are doing in China
human brain into a monkey dude I
wouldn't want that well actually they're
stronger I'll want that Gaby you're dead
why why would they be your friend no
like I'm gonna be the king of monkey how
because I'm still a monkey a monkey a
man wearing a be a good human shirt oh
yes I love these people because they're
always the [ __ ] [ __ ] who was
robbing a liquor store he was caught on
camera stealing items worth $100,000
from a jewelry workshop I knew it he was
doing a good gym you wouldn't he was
gonna give it to charity [ __ ] he's Robin
Hood Robin Hood yeah well he was there
for a whole hour and they're also
calling him what was it a pooper trader
because he also took advantage of other
facilities in the building dad that
looked like someone's home yeah broke in
and stole jewelry that's a Vietnamese
jewelry store for sure dude look at that
relax back area dude yeah so the type of
jewelry he stole was from this like Etsy
store was that turquoise they make like
these are really gems damn so he stole
from like a small business it doesn't
seem like uh I thought it was another
kind of jewelry store diamonds and [ __ ]
yeah yeah some reason I'm less
sympathetic to that I'd be like oh I see
now it's like he stole from an arts and
crafts store yeah yeah just for sure I
mean luckily they did say that the
jewelry was insured so at least that
that's dope but so this place is called
rink rush and they
they did confirm that there was a
break-in and they're just hoping that
because of this break-in and wouldn't
like hold back all the orders and in his
sure said be a good human it's usually
the people that are like I'm a good
human I pray the but I do this I do that
are always the nastiest that's his
brother shirt he stole that hoodie to do
the job so he just grabbed it it just
has no sense of irony he's like guys a
shirt the shirt yeah [ __ ] it maybe he
was wearing it to also be a disguise cuz
he's like there's no way in hell people
think that I'm a bad guy cuz I'm wearing
this shirt because I mean robbers don't
look like robbers yeah that's the
stupidest robber to look like you know
what I saw the other day well I'm not
sure if I saw but I think somebody got
there like their [ __ ] or their wallet
Jack there's some [ __ ] you know how we
talked about when if you see something
go down like Oh what we would do I did
it I froze cuz I couldn't figure out
what was going on you saw it happen
right in front of you somebody they were
like grabbing some [ __ ] in the
percentage and I was like [ __ ] what's
going on and then I kind of realized
that I think the person just got jacked
what happened with he crying going like
why just got out of mind you know my
Honda Element I'm saying well I got side
but they kind of looked like they were
arguing or something so it to me it
seemed like two people were they knew
each other but uh was it a guy in a girl
it was two dudes oh that's a guy he
could but then it doesn't register in
your head what's going on because you're
not thinking that somebody's getting
robbed the whole time huh I guess I
guess what I was like was this like they
were really close I was in the parking
lot they were standing in front of a
Jamba Juice but something will happen we
just [ __ ] and the guy just Jed and the
guy like hey and I was like wait were
they fighting word that person is
getting robbed I say that person just
got robbed what if it what if you
realize what was happening in that same
second I think I would have been the
same thing I think it would have just
happened right here Bryce one like this
would have happened cuz I do don't you
know decided like I'm not gonna help how
far were you would you be able to catch
it oh no no I was pretty far out but it
just didn't register in my head cuz it's
so shocking so now
when every time I see something what
people are like you should have done
something
oh you don't know what to do you just
kind of it's just still a sec you know
it's another one that the situation like
that that happens is when you have a kid
and you don't think that they're gonna
do the dumb [ __ ] that they're about to
do and then they do it you're like I
could have prevented you just don't
think that they're gonna like not crying
yeah or that they're just gonna like
throw themselves down some stairs or
something and you kind of see it
happening you're like no I have a watch
your guys's walls in a very long time
but ever since like pikas beginning
older because I haven't seen him a lot
that's the only way I can see him
because I'm traveling a ship but but you
just say you're a fan no I'm a fan of
Tiger is so [ __ ] funny cuz this Fool
has the funniest [ __ ] laugh dude it's
kind of like your laugh is that your
chronic like kids are so weird like that
yeah they do something in the new motion
changes like that instantly bipolar yeah
like you'll fall their member he hit his
head on the backpack kids are yeah they
kind of do things to get their [ __ ]
way and when they get one of the
funniest news I saw him do he was uh
like doing something wasn't getting his
way and he cries he throws his head back
throws it back into a bookshelf prizes
I'm like that's what you get
[ __ ] he they're so funny - cuz
like he'll be mad like one of you
specifically we're taking something away
but at he's crying he's not happy what
comfort so funny dude kids are [ __ ]
wild you know you're saying it takes a
minute to register things yeah they're
ever tell you about when a bike got
stolen right in front of me no so in
high school I used to ride a bike to go
see my girlfriend I was like fifteen or
sixteen and I wrote it right in front of
her house we're just chilling on her
front lawn and I had my bike like on the
sidewalk we're on the front lawn like
his children and then this car pulls up
in front and it's a mom like a maybe
like 50 year old like Latino woman and
then a kid they pull up right on friends
we're just talking and then the kid
comes out gets on my bike and just just
starts pedaling on
but like you said like when things
happen it does you know it's a process
you don't think you're getting jacked
right in front of you yeah so he gets on
and he starts riding off and I'm like
just jacked my bike dance [ __ ]
and then I started running but then this
was on a bike so I might get back your
[ __ ] II just go it's farther and
farther mom dropped a mother still it's
still a [ __ ] bike so I stopped take
off my shoe and I just tried to chuck it
cuz I'm like just walking back and I'm
like I can't believe my bike got jacked
in front of me in front of my
girlfriend's house no wonder you always
use that for Mexican it's feeling bike
well that's like the third time my bike
got stolen by me it was isn't it crazy
though it doesn't register it in your
[ __ ] it's so latent it feels like I'm
in molasses or something it's called
normalcy bias it's it's it refers to our
tendency to always maintain status quo
in our mind so even when there's like
gunshots ringing out people have been
documented to be like is that yeah
you're like a firework so they're
shooting a movie it's like a real human
reaction of just like this is something
that's not common in like your everyday
things so like especially cuz it
happened in South Pasadena you know so
it's a very nice area yeah
so I don't know what the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was it was so weird now this was an all
ham bro wasn't a bad neighborhood yeah
we're just chilling and my bike gets
stolen right upfront you wouldn't go to
a bad neighborhood of steal bikes you
would go to a good neighborhood story
being an attorney damn David just pull
me apart today no idea you're so cute so
a dog groomer pulls a gun on a couple
that was late picking up their dog do
you think yeah go crazy
speaker appointment was that five and
this without the other cigarette smell -
[Music]
yeah so they close at six they came
after six the business owner
pulled out a gun because according to
her the owner was being very
disrespectful and yelling
at her and so that's why she pulled it
out and like tapped it on the counter to
gangster this don't but an employee of
the business said no the dog leader is
actually very respectful and apologized
for being late to pick up his dog but
then that's when the owner was very
agitated went to the back pulled out the
gun and then like waved it around
telling the business the dog owner to
leave and the employee also told the
police that the business owner was
smoking weed and so what's your attitude
boss right now I'm not gonna have a job
anymore my god I was like volunteering
extra information no and then also so
they mentioned the employee mentioned to
the police that the owner told the
employee I'm not gonna tell I'm not
gonna give them this gun I'm gonna give
them this other gun when they come why I
don't know employee ended up telling the
cops that too so they found both guns
and they found marijuana you don't like
that that boss at all that woulda sunk
like the the bosses they're talking to
the cop egos let me tell you what
happened I just tapped the gun cuz I was
being rude on the [ __ ] working behind
it like that's not what happened be so
bad
56 years old she is the business owner
she looks like a mean [ __ ] ya know she
looks like she's she does witchcraft on
a part-time permanent frown wrinkles I
know
does she she does a dog grooming thing
yeah I would never leave my dog know
like that dude she looks like she
[ __ ] uses dogs and her seances and
[ __ ] maybe that's why she wanted the dog
not smiling like you should show a
picture of her like smile maybe she
maybe she's got a nice smile she looks
like she hates her cuz I know if the
customer was being rude they would be
like yeah she doesn't like a badass
[ __ ] right she just looks like she
smells like cigarette butts she smells
like weed David she smells like weed
people would we don't look like that so
she was arrested for aggravated assault
threatening to use a gun in a fight drug
possession possession of drug
paraphernalia and possession of a weapon
by a restricted person damn that extra
info though that's that's so funny yeah
yeah no she waved the gun around but
also she smoked weed ones yeah and also
five years ago there was this one time
that's like well commit tattletale
Richard why would you say nobody even
asked you what if they fought that day
probably an employee was like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] yeah I wouldn't hire that employee
I could write a stream she hasn't moved
those lips are way too damn loose
because in having it being an employee's
like being a part of a gang like you got
to protect your [ __ ] boss at all
costs or a commission job well I mean if
your boss protected you then you do that
habit if your boss is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you're like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
yeah that's true but if she's got a gun
like that and she's willing to protect
the time of the business I think she
would maybe protect me I'm like that's
the kind of boss I want what would shoot
you for being late to work who was that
gun in there for my hold on a second
leaves punctual why does she have a gun
who robs pet stores hey you know you
never know yeah I've never had a
grooming place be robbed before man you
tell me you guys are the ones with the
gun laws so yeah and then we have dogs
in there so they could just I'm Yura got
puppies that would be dope nature's gun
dogs are [ __ ] expensive dude maybe
that'd be a good [ __ ] teacup poodle I
don't know just like any well it would
be a cash business cuz a lot of people I
mean like barber shops and stuff too you
know it's a lot of cash go for French
bulldogs can go anywhere like three
grands French bulldogs corgis those are
expensive designer does just shut your
ass up
no I just don't see that happy I've
never seen it I've been kidnapping dogs
would be harder than humans though
[ __ ] Wiggly little creatures that
bite you I think you just give them
stake in each other yeah yeah I hope
it's that easy cuz there's a lot of dogs
I would like to own oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]